depuis la légalisation du cannabis cette
industrie a connu une croissance
fulgurante d'immenses complexes de cerf
ont été bâties de toutes pièces d'autres
ont été reconvertis pour accueillir
cette culture mais faire pousser du
cannabis ça demande beaucoup d'eau et
d'énergie à moins qu'on décide de faire
les choses autrement
[Musique]
le paysage des villes canadiennes a
changé depuis quelques années
des centaines de magasins de cannabis
ont maintenant pignon sur rue
dans cet quartier on dirait qu'ils sont
perdus
le cannabis vendu au Canada et cultivé
par plus de 500 producteurs d'un peu
partout au pays
dans ce nouveau marché hautement
concurrentiel
certaines entreprises sont convaincues
que le succès financier voire même la
survie de l'industrie passe par la
production de cannabis plus
éco-responsable l'industrie avant qu'on
commence avait des forts doutes sur
notre capacité à mettre sur le marché un
produit de qualité par rapport aux défis
que ça représente tout le monde n'est
pas prêt à s'engager sur cette voie mais
nous savons que c'est l'avenir et que
dans deux ou trois ans tout le monde le
sera
[Musique]
en Alberta la toute nouvelle usine de
l'entreprise freedom cannabis ouvre ses
portes
7500 plans de cannabis qui poussent dans
un espace de 1400 mètres carrés
il s'agit d'un système hydroponique on
se sert de l'eau pour alimenter en
nutriments les racines des plantes
[Musique]
une usine de cette taille consomme 13500
litres d'eau par jour
nous arrosons nos plantes de 5 à 8 fois
par 24 heures ça fait beaucoup d'eau
cannabis installe donc un système
hautement spécialisé pour récupérer et
assainir une partie de ces taux
cultivateur à l'usine
voici la salle d'irrigation c'est ici
que la magie se passe voici notre
réservoir d'eau fraîche et là ce sont
nos réservoirs d'engrais le bruit que
vous entendez c'est la pompe qui envoie
le mélange d'eau et d'engrais aux
plantes et nous récupérons ensuite
toutes ces taux
on utilise moins d'engrais que d'autres
usines puisqu'il reste des nutriments
dans l'eau que nous récupérons et que
nous envoyons de nouveau aux plantes
l'entreprise dit pouvoir insérer de 65%
ces intrants et conserver 500 ml d'eau
fraîche par année
ne souffrent pas vraiment de se
recyclage d'eau comme vous le voyez
elles sont en pleine forme
cannabis ont tous besoin de lumière
beaucoup de lumière
dans une usine comme celle-ci
l'éclairage est environ 25 fois plus
puissant que les lampes fluorescentes
conventionnelles
on rejoint Scott things directeur des
communications dans la salle des
machines
nous évitons carrément le soleil lorsque
les plans commencent à pousser on règle
la luminosité au plus bas
comme si on était en été et quand arrive
la saison des récoltes et que le
cannabis est mature on a juste de
nouveau
c'est une plante qui coûte très cher à
produire
l'usine consomme autant d'électricité
par année que 2500 maisons moyennes en
Alberta
[Musique]
pour réduire ses coûts en électricité
freedom cannabis se dot de l'un des plus
grands toits solaires commerciaux au
pays
4500 panneaux capables de générer 1800
kW soit 100% de sa consommation
d'électricité
un système qui permet de réduire de 1000
tonnes par année la production de gaz à
effet de serre
nous avons fait des choix que d'autres
ne veulent pas faire en raison des coûts
exorbitants nos coûts de production pour
un gramme de cannabis sont probablement
parmi les plus élevés sur le marché
le système de récupération d'eau le toit
solaire et l'utilisation de contenant
entièrement recyclable ont coûté plus de
5 millions de dollars à l'entreprise
quand l'usine sera pleinement
fonctionnelle les bénéfices dépasseront
amplement les cours originaux
[Musique]
on se dirige vers un caster dans le sud
de l'Ontario
voici la nouvelle serre de l'entreprise
de Green organ
[Musique]
les sols de croissance sont étalés sur
une superficie de plus d'un hectare où
pousse 75000 plantes de cannabis un
système entièrement biologique
[Musique]
on nourrit le sol puis on laisse le
loisir à la plante de se nourrir
elle-même à partir de ce qu'on donne au
sol c'est pour ça qu'on appelle la
culture en sol vivant donc on lui donne
plusieurs nutriments on utilise du sirop
d'érable on utilise de la Chine on
utilise des liquides de crustacés donc
ça nous permet encore là de favoriser le
développement durable
Michel gagné explique que le sol vivant
permet aussi d'éviter tous les déchets
générés par l'utilisation de substrat
inerte ce petit substrat de croissance
là on devrait envoyer ça au dépotoir au
volume qu'on a ici on parle de 50 000 kg
que ça représente
chaque année 50 000 kilos là si on veut
visualiser la superficie on parle
d'équivalent d'un terrain de football
la soeur est aussi munie d'un toit
transparent qui permet à la lumière du
soleil d'entrer aux besoins
tigode réduit ainsi de moitié sa
consommation d'électricité
l'autre moitié provient d'une centrale
de cogénération
à introduisant notre électricité on
génère un produit qui est la chaleur les
plans ont besoin de chaleur et de
refroidissement donc on a des systèmes
qui nous permettent de gérer tout ça au
meilleur moment de la journée pour
limiter notre nos besoins d'énergie
puis il y a la question de l'eau pour
cultiver autant de cannabis il en faut
50 ml par jour toutes ces eaux provient
d'un bassin de rétention de 4 millions
de litres alimentées par l'eau de pluie
et de la neige ça prendrait une
sécheresse de 6 mois pour qu'on ait
besoin d'un apport d'eau différent que
l'eau de la pluie des systèmes très
coûteux qui ont un but quand même celui
de réduire l'empreinte environnementale
de la serre ça représente un
différenciateur important pour nous à
travers toutes les autres entreprises
donc quand on dit qu'on fait le pari
c'est que on espère que de plus en plus
la demande va être là puis justifier les
efforts qu'on fait
si les entreprises canadiennes comme
freedom cannabis et tigode ont choisi
d'incorporer ces technologies dans leurs
immeubles c'est qu'elles ont appris de
l'expérience de nos voisins du sud
les Américains ont ouvert la voie en
étant les premiers à construire des
installations
et on se demande comment éviter les
erreurs qui ont été faites ont vu
corriger le tir
[Musique]
la culture du cannabis allait faire
récréatifs elle légale dans certains
États américains depuis 2012 au Colorado
par exemple des dizaines d'usinés de
sœurs ont ouvert leurs portes rapidement
pour profiter de cette ruée vers l'or
vert
la consommation d'énergie n'était pas
une priorité au départ
une étude de 2017 avec conclu qu'1% de
l'électricité consommée aux États-Unis
servait à produire du cannabis
des chercheurs de l'Université du
Colorado ont aussi démontré que la
production d'un kilo de cannabis séché
aux États-Unis génère en moyenne
3600 kg de CO2
en comparaison la production d'un kilo
de tomates dans une serre chauffée au
gaz naturel en Colombie Britannique
génère deux kilos de CO2
ça s'explique surtout par la quantité
d'énergie utilisée pour le chauffage la
climatisation la ventilation et
l'éclairage dans la production
intérieure de cannabis
au Canada plusieurs entreprises
cherchent à se démarquer en réduisant
leur empreinte carbone mais les systèmes
de production moins énergivores coûte
cher ce qui représente un défi majeur
dans une industrie où la marge de profit
est déjà très mince si on prend les
coûts de production on ajoute les coûts
normaux de produire un produit marketing
les employés et tout une fois qu'on
rajoute les taxes c'est très difficile
en ce moment pour les entreprises de
cannabis arrivaient à une viabilité
financière toute la compression de prix
qui a été fait dans le marché légal pour
compétitionner contre le marché illégal
a été faite sur le dos des producteurs
elle ajoute toutefois que malgré
l'écoutes très élevé des systèmes de
production plus durables les entreprises
devraient faire le saut afin d'assurer
leur pérennité en 2022 ça juste du bon
sens au niveau de bâtir une entreprise
alors n'importe quelle compagnie qui
veut être encore en existence au 5 10 15
ans doit prendre le développement
durable en compte
les entreprises canadiennes qui ont déjà
fait le virage en sont convaincus
de temps avant que nos compétiteurs
fassent la même chose que nous on
restera quand même des pionniers et
c'est certainement notre plus grand
avantage sur le plan concurrentiel
on est tout à fait confiant que de plus
en plus et rapidement le consommateur va
reconnaître ça l'industrie va connaître
ça puis on va être en bonne position à
ce moment-là d'avoir fait les bonnes
choses
[Musique]